the fourth of july shootings uh suspect
suspect charged with seven counts of
first-degree murder on tuesday the lake
county state attorney eric reinhardt
announced that a suspect robert creamo
iii
has been charged with seven counts of
first-degree murder in connection to the
mass shooting at highland park fourth of
july parade we anticipate dozens of more
charges centering around each of the
victims psychological victims physical
victims attempted murder charges
aggravated discharge
discharge charges aggravated battery
charges
there will be dozens more charges
against mr cremo but these seven counts
of first degree murder will lead to a
mandatory life sentence should he be
convicted without the possibility of
parole uh and then you have a couple
other stories i'll read one of them here
to you uh uh highland park tells the um
boom uh police flagged highland park
shooter clear and present danger in 2019
he later cleared four background checks
robert bobby cremo the third 21 years
old the suspect in a mass shooting that
killed seven people and wounded dozens
of others on fourth of july parade was
still able to clear state-required
background checks to purchase firearms
on at least four separate occasions
between 2020 and 2021 the illinois state
police reported in september 2019 isp
received a clear and present danger
report on the subject from the highland
park police department the report was
related to threats the subject made
against his family
and not willing to move forward on a
complaint next thing you know obviously
this is documented and even take place
you have any thoughts on this adam
i mean
at this point we're just going to go run
around in circles and talk about what
needs to get done here and you know
background checks uh
health uh mental health the gun it's it
just we're just talking in circles here
you talked about you shot a video and
you're like oh we need a after uvalde a
how-to video what can we do about gun
control and you talked about well i
think we need to redo the video because
of this shooting and then i
not even sarcastically i said well don't
wait too long to do that because there's
going to be another shooting
and that's the
look we're going to talk in circles here
the kid somehow his father co-signed to
get the gun
and he passed these uh background checks
somehow this kid you showed a video
today that he reenacted what he would do
and nobody did nothing so
i think you know extreme times drastic
times called for drastic measures
i'm going to give an angle that nobody i
don't hear talking about
the family of this person or the family
of any shooter what happens to them
nothing what happens like i understand
that the father didn't pull the trigger
or
the grandma or the uncle paul but
these people have a complete lack of
regard for human life
but i assume at some in some level in
their life this person cares about his
grandma or cares about his dad or his
family or a sister
and i'm not saying that those people
need to go to jail over this
but that family
something needs to happen to have
accountability whereas as you're about
to this [ __ ] kid dresses up as a
woman covers up his tattoos and he's
going on a roof and he's about to shoot
a bunch of people
and he knows that he's going to say all
right once i do this i'm going to jail
the rest of my life or i'm gonna die
and that's it he's only thinking about
himself but in the back of your mind if
you're an active shooter and you're
thinking whoa hold on
this is really my entire family is gonna
uh
face the ramifications of this or my
grandma's going to go to jail i'm going
way completely out of people and i like
i like maybe that will be like well and
trigger no pun intended something an
embassy you know what
i love my family too i hate myself i
hate people the girl that didn't want to
kiss me in school the video game my butt
like
something extreme needs to be done here
because if it's still red flag laws
background checks mental health you know
accessibility to guns it's the same
[ __ ] talking points we need to do
something different and you know what
tripped me out about this story when i
heard this and how it's crazy how this
happened in chicago right how this gets
only this type of mass shooting got it's
you know people are still talking about
was all big do you know how many mass
shootings are and you talked about this
adam a couple podcasts ago it's like
three or more people right uh chicago
from september of may uh 2018 until
today
811 people killed or injured in mass
shootings this this one's the only one
that gets this past weekend i think
there was like 80 years some people shot
and like i think another 9 or 10 on top
of this it's just crazy how that gets
stored it's those people that were at
the parade that mattered but all the
people that are getting killed all the
minorities inside chicago that mayor
whoever is the mayor of chicago i get it
horrible job
what do you do like like we keep talking
about changing everything you guys got
to do how do you how do you still have a
job as a mayor of chicago i know it's a
whoever comes in it's horrible none of
them are really doing anything here's a
crazy thing about this this uh this guy
his father
ran against the current highland parks
mayor as a mayor mayoral race i don't
know if you got what i just said the
democratic killers the the guy that did
that his dad ran against the current
mayor of the city where he was shooting
wow
that's that's a little creepy right
there
yeah when you hear the story i think the
takeaway is when your son shows up at
home and he has a tattoo on his forehead
and on his cheek you've got a problem
and don't let him get a gun
or would they wear those tight tight um
army shoes that yeah and you know people
my dad would have kicked my ass
if i would have shown up i mean my dad
used to not let me come into the house
without having to look at him in the eye
yes this [ __ ] about you get into your
house late at night when your parents
are yeah of course you know what my dad
would do he went to sleep in my bed to
make sure i had to wake him up but and
then i had to face him to make it sure i
wasn't stoned or drunk or i had
something else going there's a lot of
it's called accountability so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]